[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america
let's find out what happened
president-elect joe biden this week
attended a news conference in delaware
and that's it he didn't attack the press
or
use any racial slurs or declare war on
luxembourg
he just went to a news conference and
then he went home
that man is so boring and i love it
yes whoa
public libraries in the netherlands
recently pulled a children's book off
the shelves
that showed images of a racist character
even crazier
this was the book
see he's trump he's he's a real
wacky guy the world's
last known white giraffe was recently
fitted with a gps
tracking device while a black giraffe
was recently followed around walgreens
that was why are these leaves
locked behind this thing i'm just trying
to i'm just trying to get some lotion
why is it locked behind
us it was announced
this week they lock up
all the lotion
i mean it's so sad but they better
because i'm a user
it was announced this week that
filmmaker spike lee will direct a
musical about the launch of
erectile function drug viagra
it's called she really gotta have it
it's called
do the right thingy it's called malcolm
sex
it's called mobetta blue balls it's
called
black clans man it's called love and
basketballs
loving basketball was a spikely movie he
produced it i'll allow it
experts this week estimated that nearly
one in 100 americans currently have the
coronavirus
said americans then i'll only have 99
people over for thanksgiving
i'm steve urkel the american
a gym owner in london last week was
fined
67 000 pounds after keeping his business
open during a lockdown
even crazier who he was keeping it open
for
can you believe it
it's the queen yeah what if the queen
were strong we're the only show brave
enough to
take a look and find out no one cares
and finally
president trump's motorcade passed his
supporters at a march last weekend
and trump was seen giving two thumbs up
one thumb for
every month he has left an office cause
he lost
woo and that was the monologue i hope
you guys liked it
no as i just mentioned
donald trump officially lost the
election he is no longer going to be
president
yeah derek that's a good thing why are
you bummed
no no no it's great that guy sucks it's
it's just i was just starting to finally
nail my trump impression
you know now no one's gonna want to hear
it it's
well i still want to hear it really yeah
i'm sure it's great go ahead okay
um let me get in the character um
say hi to my nephews huey dewey
and louie wait what huey dewey and louie
that's not donald trump that's donald
duck
oh my bad uh you're right um
this is america that's donald glover
torture is a-okay
that's donald rumsfeld this is cnn
tonight
that's dom lemon welcome to wallburger
that's donnie wahlberg
okay fine you know i'm not i'm not gonna
do it anymore you know i'm doing a great
job
i'm doing a perfect job actually some
say the best job anyone has ever done
but all i hear is negativity i'm being
treated so unfairly everyone's against
me
it's because you're jealous you're
jealous of how smart and handsome i am
it's sad whoa okay that's a very good
trump impression
yeah yeah it works it's perfect
especially the part where you actually
seem like you're not sad inside
yeah you okay tarek yeah yeah
yeah i'm good um i can't tell if you're
lying but either way it's time to move
on
but that's fair now ever since the
election there's been a lot of talk in
the media online
and maybe even in your white family's
group chat about how it's a time to
reach out to republicans who are upset
about the election
about how it's important to build
bridges to trump supporters and
to find common ground with them and i
just wanted to let each and every person
out there know that you
100 absolutely do not have to do that
in all honesty i would suggest you don't
and here's why
trump supporters are racist and if you
create a space for racists
to thrive they will and is that
something you want
truly can cindy come over to your house
and be like yuck
mexicans because if so you are providing
a safe
place for her racism to flourish don't
be
like that giving a racist your time and
energy is like giving a seed water and
light it helps them grow into a flower
but not a normal flower one of those
terrifying flowers from little shop of
horrors
you don't owe them anything especially
forgiveness because it's okay if you
don't forgive them for what they've done
separating families empowering white
supremacists
bringing back kid rock your sympathy and
empathy are important and necessary
gifts but
you don't have to give those gifts away
at the expense of your humanity
it is not a white elephant party with
your office
it's a red elephant party and all of
their gifts are bad and hate black
people
so if you needed someone to tell you
this here goes
you do not have to go to their weddings
and you do not have to invite them to
yours
your uncle isn't weird weird uncles have
eye patches and tell ghost stories
your uncle is a racist and if he has an
eye patch
you have a weird uncle who is also a
racist
and whenever we can have thanksgiving
together again you don't have to go
and if you do go you can tell everybody
that uncle patchy ain't [ __ ]
now to be clear i'm not saying anything
radical
i'm not saying burn it down
yet but really i'm not saying cuss
everyone out i'm just saying
you don't have to be sweet to everyone
kindness is your gift to dole out as you
see fit
and i really want you to hear this
searching for the good
in someone who thinks nothing of you is
how they condition
us to become accustomed to being treated
like [ __ ]
don't become accustomed to being treated
like [ __ ]
you don't have to be nice to trump
supporters you don't have to find ways
to get close to them in fact you
shouldn't get close to them because
they're probably not wearing a mask
they deserve to lose and they lost and
they're allowed to be
sad but you're allowed to laugh at them
because after all the things they did to
us
this [ __ ] is funny as hell
[Music]
[Applause]
you